one of the hardest evenings I ever spent
was that combination and I will never do
that again but I haven't been able to
line up too much support the question is
what about combining Bhagawan harmala
with mushrooms with stir fara cubensis
now what happened to me was I took half
a dose of mushrooms which for me would
be two and a half grams I took two and a
half grams of mushrooms with half the
dose of ayahuasca and it was it was
seemed crazy making to me very very very
unpleasant State I was I think what was
happening as I analyzed it later was
that short-term memory absolutely would
not transcript and so I got into this
strange loop which went like this
something's wrong what's wrong
nothing's wrong okay something's wrong
what's wrong nothing's wrong
okay and it it was get it was serious
and it went on for about an hour and I I
just did not know what to do i I had the
image from 2001 of the guy outside the
ship saying
open the pod doors how saying I can't do
that Dave
open the pod door is how I'm sorry Dave
and it really seemed to me I could
almost see an enzymatic I almost had
like a nano engineer's view of the
problem I could see it the synaptic
level that the molecular machinery was
lodged in some peculiar configuration
and and I did and I you just I was broke
into a sweat and I and I just said okay
I'm going to sit here till this goes
away I'm not going to start screaming
I'm not going to call for help I'm not
going to do anything I'm just going to
wait until this goes away and then I
started deep breathing as a strategy for
metabolizing and after 45 minutes or so
it
kind of jiggled loose and then it was
like oh wow what a plumber that was